الاستروكس
يعود التباين الاوروبي في احدى اكثر
القضايا تاثيرا على الاسواق الغاز بعد
ولاده عسيره الاتفاق يقضي بوضع سقف للسهر
النفط الروسي تتصاعد نظر انقسام سياسيا في
ملف الغاز الاختلافات الاوروبيه ليست
وليده لحظه فما واقف العديد من دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي ترى واحد بين الرفض
والحذر بل وحتى التحذير في ضم ازمه الطاقه
المستمره منذ بدء حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
وارتفاع معدلات الاستهلاك في فصل الشتاء
لكن وثيقه للبنك المركزي الاوروبي كشفت عن
مواطن القلق المتزايده خلف الابواب
المغلقه وجاء فيها ان وضع سقفا لاسعار
الغاز في اوروبا قد يهدد الاستقرار المالي
تم تقلق يساوي البنك المركزي الاوروبي
بشان الخطوه وانعكاساتها الماليه على
مستوى الاتحاد الاوروبي وذلك مع استمرار
النقاشات على مختلف مستويات العمل المشترك
داخل اروقه الاتحاد الاوروبي من اجل
التوسل الاتفاق بشان اسعار الغاز مسؤولان
اوروبيان كشفان سقف الاسعار المقترح هو
220 يورو لكل ميجاوات ساعه
لكن كل هذه الاقتراحات قد تتغير قبل
واثناء اجتماع وزراء الطاقه في دول
الاتحاد المرتقب الثلاثاء المقبل وللتذكير
فشله لاجتماع السابق لوزراء الطاقه اواخر
الشهر الماضي في الاتفاق على وضع حد اقصى
لاسعار الغاز الروسي
يتزامن ذلك مع اعلان المانيا وهولندا
والنمسا والدنمارك
ولوكستونيا
معارضتها توسيعا نطاق السقف المقترح
لاسعار الغاز الطبيعي في سوق الاتحاد
الاوروبي ليشمل التعاملات قصيره الاجل
وحجه هذه الدول ان اي تدخل يجب ان يضمن
الحفاظ على تنافسيه الاسعار في المنطقه مع
بقيه دول العالم
والبديل الذي تطرحه الدول الست اليه تصحيح
السوق بما يسمح بتعليقها اليا وفق فين
محدده يحدث هذا في وقت تتجه فيه موسكو
لاتخاذ اجراءات مضاده لمواجهه قرار وضع
سقف لاسعار نفطها والتلويح بما هو افدح في
حال الاقتراب من اسعار غازها الطبيعي